Okay.
Big, big, big announcement today.
Uh, after the program today I will be going
to, uh, Boston's Logan Airport and I will
be flying hopefully nonstop unless there is
a change to the itinerary of my plane to Los
Angeles, California because tomorrow Wednesday
I will be appearing live.
I think it's live on the Joe Rogan program.
This is extremely exciting.
Have been, um, trying to put this together
with Joe for a while.
I was not planning on taking time off from
the show this week or anytime soon, are really
up until the 4th of July break because I was
just gone.
And this came together very quickly.
The flights came together very quickly.
Uh, June 5th, Wednesday, June 5th at 3:00
PM Eastern noon Pacific.
I will be on with Joe Rogan.
It will be a wide ranging and informative
conversation.
I am going in excited to talk to Joe about
what am I for as a progressive leftist and
I think it is a great opportunity to talk
about what it is that I stand for.
What are my views.
Uh, we will talk about media, we will talk
about online, a media culture and Youtube
burrs and censorship and platforming hopefully
and all of this stuff and probably many other
things.
I have no idea about as many Joe Rogan conversations
tend to sort of take a life of their own.
So I will be away from the show Wednesday,
Thursday and the plan is, and I have such
bad luck with flights that I always say the
plan is that I will be flying back to Boston
Thursday and we'll be back on the show Friday
and we will do a full regular Friday show
with a new stories and audience questions
and live calls and all of that stuff.
If it changes, I will make sure that Benjamin
Dixon, the guest host that we are going to
have in, lets you know about that.
Ben has very graciously and on relatively
short notice, agreed to fill in for me on
Wednesday and Thursday while I am away, I
will be appearing on some other shows as well.
Uh, but the main attraction is going to be
appearing with Joe Rogan tomorrow, Wednesday.
So wish me luck.
I am sort of nervous about it.
It's a big audience.
I want to make the best possible impression
for what I do and for what my views are.
Um, but all I can do is show up and talk to
Joe and do the best I can.
So that is what's going on.
Um, our, our membership audience learned about
this on yesterday's bonus show telling everybody
today.
So that's where I will be.
And I'm trying to think if there's anything
else to mention about this.
Uh, I guess not.
Um, I will be.
Oh, um, I have some interesting lunches and
dinners scheduled while in Los Angeles with
some progressive personalities that many of
you will recognize.
So follow my Instagram, David.
Dot.
Pacman.
Follow the adventure.
I'll probably be posting some pictures from
some of these meetups that I think you'll
very interesting meetups, not audience meetups,
but just meeting up with other Los Angeles
based progressive online media personalities.